we're running out I'll start making this
let's ride if gather you you must
Syd Jaques must be wine drinkers
I brought Lathan back and what does
valsartan do I knew and trust me
this isn't payam bras is impressed and
truly frightened by the very strange sky
ah here comes your friends now just
remember you were never here
Rosenberg but a place that doesn't rise
the Kapoor eat our true optionally
simply put
you are terrific father saw her daughter
Lisa you were always elder ways here oh
wow
I envied the way she looked up to you
I'm sorry Ethan I should have been there
with you with her at the end you were
trying to save her I know that it was
just damn it we need to win this now
this shrine Val and I built it for our
daughter after she died high elves don't
bury their dead but we needed something
to remember her by
she loved climbing this tree before the
illness took her I forgot how beautiful
it was not in the least things will
never be the same between me and Nathan
again but I think we understand each
other a little better now funny how the
approaching end of the world has a way
of putting everything into perspective
I've been a member of the city order for
more years than I can remember but this
is the first time since my daughter's
illness that I've been truly frightened
about what's to come the world ends all
the time it's just that I'm more
accustomed to that being a personal
event and not a shared experience the
world ended when the Reich master died
for example you have a way of instilling
confidence my friend your similar to the
right master in that regard if we can't
have him at our side for this I'm glad
to at least have you I just hope we can
see our way through this I'll meet you
at the cave
you
you
hey guys dr. Z okay one of the big
outstanding questions right now in the
whole Koba 19 thing is how fatal is it
and how many people have already been
infected and the answers to those
questions have been stunningly hard to
get it's only been a few months but
still we don't have that data and now
we're starting to get some signal so
over the last couple days Stanford
pre-released it hasn't been peer
reviewed yet a study where they looked
at 3,300 people in Santa Clara County
that's the authority to sunspots in
California where they that people talk
about where it's a rapid dot at this
nasal test you're looking fine can
establish call reality shows effectively
in fact she's ready to appear you know
willing to join lowers the stars and you
can measure those in the blood usually
takes a week or more to develop those so
when you screen people for those who
have been right so it's a way to figure
out if something the random population
really acting on it with this window
they had symptoms or not
sent forth immortal accurately avoid it
angels of my wedded wife
to describe the entire population of
Santa Clara County projected based on
what they studied on both your honor
patience has been exposed consequential
now for more clearly most of these
people are not having symptoms
protection the resolute anger you'll be
lost in the nothingness Jaime many more
people hated that have not shown up to
medical care enough not have a
documented no it's my turn
something very let me use the gift my
master gave you faith I'll get you to
personal power the numbers that you've
skipped the hardness low the crystals
known as chronic Polly's law fatality
rough remember that means of the needle
rather identifying to energy chair
contested that thousand the Bayer
promise me you'll keep those are dying I
promise you really scary Andris from you
right guys leave Morrison which is you
know do you think that's normal flu
season is 0.1 percent fatal if you get
flu 0.9 is you know quite a bit higher
than that all the way up to like four
percent and in Italy very high numbers
because Italy is one of the has one of
the oldest populations in the world and
we know what effects old people so
people who are showing up to the
hospital talking about this what this
shows is when you're infected with the
virus you
will anybody's to fight off the virus
maker more to develop illness when you
screen people for those been infected in
the past and they may have gotten better
right so it's a way to figure out if
you're sampling the random population
how many really actually got it whether
they had symptoms or not when they did
it at Stanford they found something kind
of surprising depending on which numbers
you believe in how accurate the test is
somewhere between
sent
the entire county has been exposed
infected with bit of it now
thousand at this time this is like April
night so
that have not shown
how Babel is
get tested that thousand area
what percentage of
or really scary
all the way up
has one of the oldest populations in the
world and we know what affects old
people so people were shown at the
hospital if they're older they're having
a very high mortality rate but that's a
key we're already
so what happened
so what do they figure out
make a mortality
beca's fatality in other words of all
the people who've been affected whether
or not they showed up or diagnosed that
way
what's the
there
percent swine flu is around point to a
normal flu season is around point one of
course it's all at once and again I'm
not sure I fully believe those numbers
for the following reasons there's still
quite a bit lower and I think the
overall numbers going to be quite a bit
lower and the reason is this in this
particular study there are a couple of
major flaws one is yes then we're right
you have to study them in a lot of
positive patients to make sure that when
you test a positive patient it comes up
positive so in other words is it
sensitive but then you also have to test
it in a population of people you know
are negative and make sure that that
test is negative so in other words how
specific
this
now what's interesting about this piece
is actually looked at the test they were
using it's a blood test and they
actually studied it about 30 positive
patients in eating negative
specifically all the negatives showed up
positive patients only 28 of them tested
positive so it was actually not really
sensitive so you're actually missing
some positive patients so it might even
possibly be later under estimating
the true prevalence of the disease now
the other downside is molecular studies
Facebook ads to recruit patients for the
study so you'd see us add the basic is
it hey do you want to be tested Cova and
blood to see if you're a man we don't
know exactly what they said remember
well that's what faisal study with a
people who are already concerned maybe
they've had an exposure maybe there
they've had some isn't about it your
friends have it the interior inside you
ethically results so it's another reason
that's a very crisp forget it very very
carefully but let's say that it's
roughly correct well that means that
this particular illness may be less
fatal than previously reported more
widespread are already all over the
place and therefore we have to think
about when we're talking about social
distancing which is great how do we
start to weigh the damage of all this
lockdown versus the benefit in terms of
saving lives you have to take your
infectious
so far haven't really added hopefully
studies like this
killing others that are going to be
measuring this and it'll help us
understand when we can safely reopen and
also was our response the correct
response given what we ultimately learn
about this farce now one thing I'll say
is this it's very clear that this thing
favors health care workers clear as day
because you're putting sick patients
into a health care environment and
exposing frontline health care workers
who have very little protection at least
in areas where it's short and so that
population is specifically at risk and
has every right to scream and yell about
how they've been put in danger by this
thing and if anything by putting them at
risk you amplify the infectious rate
because they go home and make other
people say in theory so we need to
protect our frontline health care
workers we need more data like this we
need to validate and study these
antibody tests to see if they actually
work and then we need an immunological
data to say do those antibodies actually
mean you're immune to the disease in
which case you get a little card saying
you're good to go go back to work and
already so that being said I just wanted
to say hey guys dr. Z okay one of the
big outstanding questions right now in
the whole code 19 thing is how fatal and
how many people have already
yeah
so over the last days Stanford
it's a big round
area and we've heard really scary
numbers from that's for people who are
sold I'm Princess Cruises if we more
likely they tested almost everyone on
the ship so they had a bigger so what
did they figure out the case
it turns out that anybody controversial
because get them right right you have
patients to make sure that when you test
upon other words is it sensitive but
then you also have to test it in a
population of people you know are
negative and make sure that that test is
negative seven over two how specific is
this happen if you get a negative person
and a negative test that's perfect but
if you get a negative person and a
positive test that's what you call it
also positive
now in this he also has a rates high
it's been artificially elevate
really a walking volcano
thirty
estimating the true prevalence of the
disease
now particular she's right exposure
maybe they're worried about maybe you
think ice each other faceless
she's gone moments where peace can take
your a new action in consideration a
magic that's held back the shadows
disgust
we don't be upon us before
it's very
at least needs earrings before and so
fight this thing if anything by putting
them at risk they go home in period so
we need to protect our frontline health
care workers were needing more data like
this we need to validate and study
you know you've been through it already
so that being said that
[Music]
welcome to another man the cove at
19-under they had a lot of news to cover
today the United States season tops the
charts with the number of tats 1867
United States daily new Cape hey guys
hey everybody welcome to undying beast
yeah this is Akuma Kyra's submission for
the look if he has one red we can aim to
anything basically I get ahead like I'll
begin to make for him I'm gonna be doing
like he needs the first one is undying
very cleanly like a weird even bother
[Applause]
anybody
well I read set up the office oh honey
so that go waste
Oh
they're out there the buildings down
that act is really good
and you click best game ever I'm just
explaining these rows again
sound effects not really really good
like I always loved his
yeah
I don't think a V the everything
anything and stuff like angry plate
let's see what happens if I get a lowest
I don't like that debate just by
existing any maps I wanted nothing I've
been empty void
bro what are you
really good jumping with somebody
ain't we not invited
tearing its horn itself
we're brownies
whoa the Beast
[Music]
I didn't want to do anything okay
let's go let's find all the flowers
Oh
hey Leon
I'll sweep in the gating clicking do the
flowers I'm noticing more crazy things
yeah anyway the next thing
really
very very effective like what yeah there
is that weird tango screeches
that walking into the batter
year
get the bad ending again yeah what's
going right up in here run to here I
really like how there are some them just
read oopy-scoopy mama do people run
around the myth it's like you just
totally missed usually misses end them
yeah I like that a lot
Oh
Oh
like a great site left that's blowing
her brains out at them I got a really
cool full yeah good job buddy the next
this was called the house in the woods I
October 22nd 1999 Daniel Lennard and his
friend rather than your anger but
missing while on a candy expedition I
think the kids despite the ground and I
really searched they were never found
there's something that names from the
kids and
yeah you can see like are you gonna be
your hand
Brendon
no this is the really good leverage game
isn't [ __ ] awesome
Wow
oh my right-click I can
that would be Porter
already
me
the
Heather Oh what she's buddy I'm trying
the board's gone yeah
character
it's nap doing that way okay we can see
everybody
yeah
proudly doing
is that the end of the lutely that was
really good like very sweet that sweet
ain't it exactly if the Blair Witch game
but I wasn't referring to that
yeah at the end
I can't go back and really finish my job
the lighthouse hey hey buddy
yeah
sure I like the way this looks
like little box lady people
like it's a see ya
it's like sin they're broken a cat
champion release lever a little hard on
that and everything reader
[Music]
all right
by
week 35 so the first one was week six
I'll know if that popped up on OBS back
out here again No
these blood-red trees like that yeah I
want one give it to you
okay
doing
here
everybody later tater see you next week
oh my god 34
[Applause]
oh yeah this means this right here
with wood you don't get in here
[Applause]
[Applause]
don't eat any meat no again well they're
just like call any other the island
everything oh my god
never never I'm very relaxed already it
powers lately you know not return I was
very well those looks like patty
mayonnaise thank you
the [ __ ] fishermen down here say
something creepy and cryptic to me
no that is that is completely ominous
and threatening help ladies gonna say
something like you'll be back thanks
Jesus that kid's gonna be dead
like it's still alive a little better
what fill me in what happened
looks like how to maintain them all no
no it looks like Helga Pataki's mom I'm
dog you know
would check the machine
looking up until now
what
all right
you're looking good
here buzzing applies
right
I'll guess after all this time the
classics had to change
and everything overnight
one of the machines in the back now
done here Becca me
are you still full my dude
yeah help me I like that a lot
I got let's do one more this is called
bleach right now this is actually by one
of the
today are gonna be the description as
well or like old catalog of the jams in
the game yeah I'm gonna be doing a few
of these because all the ones I played
today so far have been what
fan-fucking-tastic really enjoyed all
these Orla left and odd voicemail the
sound kept cutting out so I didn't catch
it all
hey honey I'm I be home Zions bleak
Shores love yous that's why guess I came
to teach or to find if she's okay it's
probably nothing I probably shouldn't
come here well that part is my analysis
it's gonna like soundly hill was like a
beach town [ __ ] is